this talking about games the big game
less than two weeks away and it is time
to solidify those plans and why not do
that in one of the coolest species is in
town Tony arnoni is back and he's going
to tell us a little bit more about what
you can get at the barber shop how's it
going thank you Mercedes it's going
amazing um so today I'm going to run you
through a couple of our cocktails here
you can uh get at the barbershop if you
don't know anything about the barbershop
it is a fully functioning barber shop in
the front with a secret live music venue
in the back honestly you'll never know
what kind of amazing acts you'll see in
the back and you got it you gotta knock
on the door you got to say the password
and let you in is such a blast there and
some of the coolest cocktails what are
you gonna make for us today so I did
bring you one of our custom Shooters
this is going to be a tequila cocktail
it's like in an IV bag look at them I
wrote your name on there right there
Mercedes it's all set ready for me it's
especially made for me it is it is yes
oh so what do I do just like yeah so
you're gonna unclip it and then you
would drink out of it yes like a shot
you know oh my gosh so funny I love this
this is great so you can order one of
these at The Barbers 100 you can love it
okay what'd you say is in their tequila
it is a tequila based cocktail with lime
and orjot which is like a Nutley quartz
very nice creamy refreshing cocktail
okay I'm thinking the same news for
later okay
um and another cocktail to really kick
off that uh Super Bowl is going to be
the oil and oil which is a essentially
like a smoked Manhattan cocktail okay
it's gonna have a wild turkey Long
Branch in it I love you were smoking
this earlier and the smell is just worth
the price of the cocktail alone okay is
going to be smoked cherry wood which is
that nice aromatic flavor this is a
Verna which is a sicilian Amaro and you
created this huh yes I am the lead
mixologist for click Hospitality at the
barbershop cuts and Cocktails you really
are so Innovative in your drinks I love
it thank you Maria Marnier which is a
French cognac liqueur
this adds a little bit of sweetness to
it yeah it's going to give it like that
nice round Citrus element okay cool a
couple datches dashes of orange blossom
water and angostura Bitters
and here we go that's right we've got
the ice ready to go now as you know with
your Super Bowl plans at the barbershop
we'll be showing the game on five
massive HD screens
and not only that but it's just such a
cool vibe in there the couches and just
the music are you guys going to be
having any specials for this the big
game yeah so including in some of our
packages is going to be a very very
unique Buffet which includes uh items
like wagyu sliders a very very unique uh
sweet potato fries oh wow they're
amazing dishes that our chefs have
prepared for the event that sounds
incredible how do people get information
on that so you can go to uh The
Barbershop lv.com For more information
we're going to top this off with a nice
solidified Ice Cube this is beautiful
thank you and some dehydrated orange
wheel okay drop that off and like I said
it's very aromatic with that cherry wood
I love it it seems like smoked cocktails
are really kind of huge but you can't
get anything else like our cocktails
other than the barbershop that is
absolutely delicious go spend the big
game at the barber shop cuts and
Cocktails inside the Cosmopolitan say hi
to my man Tony arnoby we'll be right
back